there's certain people that you do not
want to try and beat at their own game
and certainly Jeff Bezos would be number
one I mean that'd be like me playing
chess with Bobby Fisher you know 40
years ago to be home all over on the
first move uh Jeff no he's just showing
amazing talent in figuring out how to
please customers and in a very short
time and what's interesting to some
extent about him the same thing's
interesting about Fred Smith of federal
express it isn't that they've had some
breakthrough and you know found some
molecule this or that or or come up with
some you know incredible invention
they've taken fairly ordinary things I
mean starting buying books and you know
but Fred Smith took the airplane and the
delivery truck and the postal service
but then he just put it together in a
very imaginative way you know